- [Interviewer] Debra.
- [Debra] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Debra,
where did you grow up?
Where are you from?
- [Debra] I'm from New Orleans, Louisiana.
- [Interviewer] And how long
have you been living in LA?
- I came out here when I was 17.
- 17?
- Mm-hmm.
- [Interviewer] And you
came out with your parents?
- No, I came out here by myself.
- [Interviewer] All by yourself.
When you were living in New
Orleans, you had both parents?
- No, I only had my mom.
My real father passed away
when I was six years old.
- [Interviewer] Oh, really?
How did he pass away?
- He passed away from full
blown AIDS, 'cause he,
he stopped using drugs, but he went from
one addiction to another and he was
having a lot of unprotected
sex with different, it's either
he got it from having
unprotected sex or somebody
that worked in the
program with had tattooed
my grandmother's name, and
the needle could have been--
- [Interviewer] Oh, he got a tattoo.
- Yeah, so it could've either been from
having unprotected sex or a dirty needle.
- [Interviewer] Wow, that's sad.
And, so you came to LA at 17?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How was
your childhood growing up?
- It had its good days and its bad days.
My mom was a single mom.
She did the best she could.
Then she had a boyfriend.
And her boyfriend molested me for like,
three years, then he raped me.
I was like, 11 years
old when that happened.
Then my mom, thank god, my mom
caught him, but instead of,
she believed me.
Most women, when their kids come tell 'em,
"Oh, I've been molested,"
they believe the,
they believe the bad guy
over their own children.
My mom didn't do that.
My mom chased him out
the house down the stairs
with a big-ass knife like that.
Our neighbors that lived
across from us had to stop her
'cause she was gonna kill him.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
So when you came out here
at 17, where'd you call?
Did you have someone to stay with?
- I had a couple of friends
out here in South Central LA.
I ain't gonna lie, it was pretty cool.
I was already fucking with drugs.
I was doing powder and
ecstasy pills.
Then I start fucking with crystal meth.
- [Interviewer] In New Orleans?
- Out here.
The powder and the ecstasy pills,
I was doing that shit back home.
But when I came out here, I
started fucking with crystal.
- [Interviewer] So you've been living
on the street how long?
- How long?
(burps) I've been living on the street
since my 18th birthday.
- [Interviewer] Oh, really?
- On and off, yeah.
- [Interviewer] And
you're sleeping in a tent,
or where are you--
- I got friends that got SROs,
but most of the time,
I do sleep in a tent.
- [Interviewer] You just try
to wing it night by night?
- Yeah, depends on how I feel.
- [Interviewer] And how do you make money?
- I prostitute.
- Yeah, so most of the--
- Most of the part, yeah.
And I sell drugs every,
every blue moon.
But I'm scared to get a
fucking direct sales case.
I already got a felony on my record.
I don't need no more trouble.
- [Interviewer] What was the felony for?
- This dude put his hands
on me and I stabbed him.
I stabbed him.
I was this close to
hitting him in his heart.
So they were trying to charge me for it.
- [Interviewer] Attempted murder?
- First degree-attempted murder.
But then, I had a good lawyer,
so they dropped it down from that
to assault with a deadly weapon,
with great bodily injury.
- [Interviewer] The guys
that you pick up, I mean,
all these guys are dangerous, right?
- [Debra] I know, yeah.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How old are you now?
- 24.
- 24, so you've been doing it
for enough years to see--
- [Debra] Yeah, to see and experience.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, what
kind of stories have you got?
- [Debra] Believe it or not,
you ever heard of somebody
called the Grim Sleeper?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I heard
a lot of girls talk about--
- I dated him.
- You did?
So tell me what his MO is.
- [Debra] He pick up street workers
and he shoots them in the head.
That's his MO.
It's only me and one
other lady that actually--
- Survived.
- Survived,
that lived to tell the tale.
- [Interviewer] Is he
a white guy, black guy?
- He black, he black.
And the only reason they
call him the Grim Sleeper was
because he stopped for like, 14 years
before he started again.
And so what saved me was, I had a locket.
But I had a picture of
my niece in my locket.
And he was like, "give me one reason
"why I shouldn't kill
you, you piece of trash."
I'm like, "look, let
me show you something."
And I opened my locket up
and I'm like, "you see her?"
I'm like, "that's my daughter."
And he was like, "you better thank god.
"That's the only reason that
I ain't going to kill you."
- Really?
- Yep.
And he let me out the car,
he didn't do nothing to me,
He let me out the fucking car.
- [Interviewer] Even serial
killers have hearts. (laughs)
- It's very rare, though.
- Yeah, I know.
- No, that was God protecting me.
- [Interviewer] You're lucky.
- I don't believe in luck.
I believe in blessings and
curses, it wasn't my time.
It's been so many times where
I met death face-to-face,
and I'm still here.
- [Interviewer] And, you have a daughter?
- I told him that, that was my niece.
- [Interviewer] Oh.
- I told him that
so I wouldn't die, yeah.
- You're smart.
You're a survivor.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Interviewer] How much
money do you make in a night?
- It depends on how the
traffic is and all that.
Probably like, no less than 150.
But it all depends.
- [Interviewer] What kind
of stuff are you doing?
You're having full sex,
or just depends, or what?
- It depends on what they want.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
but you'll do everything?
- Except anal.
No, I got raped and
sodomized by a cop out here.
Yeah.
So I'm like, anybody that go near that,
I'ma fight, no, I'ma fight.
- [Interviewer] There's
easier ways to make money.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] That's horrible.
And so, you're on meth and you--
- No, I've stopped doing meth.
I stopped doing meth when
I found I was pregnant
with my oldest son when I was 19.
- [Interviewer] Oh, really?
So what are you using now?
- Crack.
I drink alcohol, I smoke weed.
And I do heroin.
I don't shoot up, I--
- Smoke it.
- Yeah, I chase the dragon.
And I snort it.
- [Interviewer] Oh, you snort it.
And that keeps you up at night?
- What?
- [Interviewer] So you end up working
through the night, not sleeping?
- It depends.
But sometimes, if it ain't
going right, I'll say "fuck it."
I'll smoke me some weed,
drink me a little bit alcohol,
eat, and go my ass to sleep.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
But there are a lot of nights
where you just don't sleep.
- Yeah.
- It's a rough life.
- Yeah, it is.
- For a 24-year-old?
- Yeah, it is a rough life.
- [Interviewer] Did you
ever finish high school?
- No.
But I'm very intelligent,
you can ask my friends.
I watch Animal Planet, History
Channel, stuff like that.
And I got a good memory, I
got like, perfect recall.
- [Interviewer] So you're pretty sharp.
- (siren wailing) Yeah,
but a lot of people think
I'm an old soul because
the way I talk about stuff.
A lot of people ask me,
have I been to college?
No, no, I dropped out in ninth grade.
I just watch educational shit
instead of reality bullshit.
This is a reality show
right here, real life.
- [Interviewer] That's why I'm here.
This is--
- You feel me?
Fuck all that Love & Hip Hop shit, nah.
This is in full live and
living color right there.
No Photoshop, no nothing.
- (laughs)
- No paycheck, no nothing,
just everyday life.
- [Interviewer] It's as
raw as I've ever seen.
- Yep.
- [Interviewer] Rarest I've ever seen.
- Right, raw, super raw.
Rawer than a motherfucking
full-rare steak.
- [Interviewer] What's
your goal down the road?
Five, 10 years from now?
- I wanted to be a doctor
growing up, but I fucked that up.
- (chuckles)
- I got that felony.
They're not going to let
me work in a hospital.
So what I want to do is
be a motivational speaker
to at-risk youth, to like, the gang-bang--
- [Interviewer] That'll
help you and help them.
- Yeah, and tell 'em, "look,
I'm a living testimony.
"You think gang banging,
selling dope, all that shit,
you think using drugs
here and there is cool?"
"Nah, bro, it ain't cool.
"It ain't cool, it ain't all fun.
"All that glitter ain't gold."
So I think that's what
I really want to do.
Be a motivational
speaker to at-risk youth.
- [Interviewer] Debra, thank you so much
for talking to me.
- No problem.
- Good luck with everything.
- You're welcome.